rumors have been spinning forever but we
finally got a look at the next Nintendo
console I'm Tony this is a game spot
news update and this is the Nintendo
switch the Nintendo switch is a hybrid
console which means you can play it at
home or remove the system from its dock
and play on the go it's both a home
console and a handheld the gamepad
itself is also adaptable you can add or
remove the new joy Khan controllers so
that one player can use to two players
can each choose one or a group can come
together to use multiple joy cons you
can also simplify things by playing with
a Nintendo switch pro controller as for
games the trailer showed off shell de
breadth of the wild skyrim mario kart 8
NBA 2k 17 splatoon and what appears to
be a new mario game nintendo also
released an image of several third-party
developers who are working on switch
games and yes those games will run on
cartridges the Nintendo switch launches
in March 2017 no price pointer list of
specs has been released although we do
know that the console runs on a custom
NVIDIA Tegra cpu there will absolutely
be more information in trailers coming
soon so keep an eye on gamespot for all
that good stuff and for all the biggest
Nintendo news you're already in the
right place
you